et là messieurs bonsoir comme hier
raymond barre françois mitterrand sera
ce soir l'invité de ce journal un peu
exceptionnel nous parlerons du retour à
new york d'un cours d'eau valdan
humiliés au cours de sa visite à téhéran
nous y parlerons aussi les nouveaux
développements de la situation en
afghanistan de l'instabilité du marché
de l'or le napoléon s'est effondré
aujourd'hui à paris et des suites de
l'incident de l'ags mail avant toute
chose je voudrais vous livrer cette
information que nous venons d'apprendre
qui n'a bien sûr pas d'incidence sur l'
équilibre du monde mais qui je crois
flora beaucoup de peine à tous ceux qui
avaient assisté à nos dossiers de
l'écran
mardi dernier c'était un débat consacré
je pense que vous en souvenez aux droits
de l'animal
une femme avait fait grande impression
joy adamson 70 ans qui toute sa vie
avait milité pour que les animaux
puissent vivre en liberté notamment les
animaux les plus dangereux
les lions par exemple eh bien hier elle
a été tuée sur les pentes du mont kenya
par un lion précisément terrible destin
1 ce qui est peut-être dans cet ultime
message qu'elle a dressé mardi dernier
au téléspectateur d'antenne de
l'instinct de chasse lui se développe
presque à la naissance du lion mais là
l'instinct de tuer n'apparaît que vers
18 mois le lion est alors est très
puissant très fort mais il lui en faut
il lui faut encore quatre mois pour
atteindre vraiment la plénitude de ses
moyens et entre le moment entre le
moment où sa mère le protège et où il
devient capable de chasser
et pour lui même il s'écoule donc quatre
mois difficiles tourné il ya huit ans au
kenya ce film montre jack adamson en
compagnie d'élise à sa lionne préféré
l'héroïne du film des dossiers de
l'écran de mardi dernier
le drame s'est produit dans la même
région sur les pentes du mont kenya au
moment où joy adamson qui étudiait la
vie des guépards a voulu s'approcher
d'un lion qui chassait un bus une
imprudence étonnante de la part de cette
femme qui a vécu 45 ans dans les
réserves du kenya et écrit plusieurs
livres dont un best-seller sur les lions
et lionnes vivre libres les voeux de
valéry giscard d'estaing aux
journalistes cet après midi le président
parlait de son programme de voyage pour
80 il visitera les deux pays les plus
peuplés du monde l'inde fin janvier et
la chine en octobre
il ira également dans les pays du golfe
persique et en jordanie en mars en
finlande en juillet et à une date encore
indéterminée au sénégal et au liberia il
publiera dans le courant de l'année un
supplément à démocratie française
enfin il a annoncé le prochain départ de
son porte-parole le pire un pneu mais
dans une grande ambassade peut-être
tunis et puis il l'a commenté
l'actualité la plus récente en
manifestant une certaine inquiétude à
propos de l'accueil qu'a reçu courval
dame en iran un cours baldan humilié qui
a en effet regagné tout à l'heure new
york au terme d'une mission ratée 8
heures à l'aéroport de téhéran ce matin
kurzweil times le secrétaire général des
nations-unies kit l'iran ferait de lui
le ministre iranien des affaires
étrangères sadegh bob radecki poliment
le raccompagne à l'air plutôt gêné pour
de valdaï mme s'en va en claquant la
porte
une façon diplomatique il s'en va dit-il
pour assister à la préparation de la
réunion du conseil de sécurité sur
l'afghanistan après trois jours passés
en iran trois jours pendant lesquels il
a été constamment injurié par la foule
vilipendé par la sas iranienne khomeiny
et ont refusé de recevoir pour monsieur
valdan l'échec sans plus flagrant c'est
presque l'humiliation arrivée à zurich
quelques heures plus tard il déclaré
on ne sait pas très bien qui appartient
le pouvoir le conseil de la révolution
les étudiants l'ayatollah khomeini ils
sont en désaccord la situation échappe à
certaines recrues monsieur baldé qui
dira plus tard avoir reçu des iraniens
des propositions qu'on ne peut pas
divulguer pour le moment peut-être bien
une façon élégante de dissimuler son
épouse van damme ne pouvait guère être
couronnée de succès quand on sait les
difficultés qui se hérissent entre les
trois principaux pôles du pouvoir à
téhéran les étudiants donc l'ayatollah
khomeiny et puis le ministre des
affaires étrangères salek goda des
encore que ces difficultés soit un petit
peu gonflé par la presse américaine
en revanche de nouveaux affrontements
entre les partisans de l'ayatollah
chariatte manarii et ceux de l'ayatollah
khomeini nous rejoignons jacques à
bouchehr en iran une gestion très
délicate également là en afghanistan les
troupes soviétiques se heurte à de
nombreux fruits et résistance malgré une
intervention énergique énergique et je
crois le mot qui convient on vient
d'apprendre que toute la famille du
président déchu le prix dans la mine
avaient été exterminés toute sa famille
c'est à dire les quatre femmes du
président et ses 24 enfants pendant ce
temps
nouveau président babrak karmal faisait
l'éloge de la politique une étrangère de
l'urss
son ministre des affaires étrangères qui
est en ce moment à moscou avant de se
rendre à l'onu s'est d'ailleurs
entretenu avec andreï gromyko son
homologue soviétique
tout cela a mené à sa dont deux
responsables a agité récemment le risque
de guerre
alors françois mitterrand vous qui est
notre invité à ce stade du journal la
paix ou la guerre ce que vous vous posez
la question est ce que cette
dramatisation ou paraît artificielle ou
fondamental que la situation soit
sérieuse ça tombe sous le sens que
quelqu'un ou plutôt que l'une des
grandes puissances veuille faire la
guerre je ne crois pas c'est pas un
argument suffisant
bien entendu car comme l'homme et
l'autre savent que l'autre ou l'un ne
veulent pas faire la guerre
chacun pousse ses pions comme s'il était
garantie à l'avance en raison même de
l'ampleur du désastre que signifierait
une guerre atomique
seulement voilà la boule échappe des
mains
parfois on l'a vu en 1914
voilà pourquoi on doit considérer la
situation comme graves mais on ne doit
pas tomber dans l'excès alarmiste
car les responsables du monde qui
peuvent faire la guerre ne voulant pas
ils peuvent encore il faut que nous les
y étions nous les français les
responsables de la politique française
il faut qu'ils ne le puissent pas donc
le chef de l'état à tort d'agiter ce
risque de bien je ne cherche pas engager
une polémique le caractère intérieur
dans cette affaire j'ai beaucoup de
choses à dire et à redire sur la
politique du gouvernement de monsieur
bart sur la politique du président la
république mais ce n'est pas le moment
pour l'instant ce que je veux dire c'est
que on ne peut pas réagir autrement
qu'en condamnant tout ce qui manque au
principe sur lequel est fondé la société
internationale
voyez-vous canton
quand on cherche son devoir ça arrive
s'interroge qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
il faut retourner aux principes les plus
simples c'est vrai dans la vie privée
c'est vrai dans la vie publique et le
principe tout simple qui préside à la
société internationale laquelle nous
vivons c'est le droit de chaque peuple à
disposer de lui même sans être soumis à
la violence une intervention militaire
depuis fort que lui l'invasion militaire
de l'union soviétique en afghanistan
n'est donc pas acceptable c'est bon quoi
s'interroger à cet égard aux mal-aimés
pourquoi car après tout lui l'union
soviétique contrôle et déjà l'aghanistan
engager une action de ce genre c'est
remettre en cause
d'abord peut-être dix ans d'histoire
passé c'est un en fait placé l'union
soviétique dans la situation aussi
trouver où se sont trouvées les états
unis d'amérique
il n'y a pas si longtemps notamment au
vietnam au cambodge
c'est en même temps créé à un problème
entre le nord communiste et le sud tiers
monde avec le monde musulman
beaucoup plus qu'un problème immédiat
est ouest
voilà pourquoi je ne comprends pas
encore dans l'état de mes informations
les raisons qui ont pu pousser l'union
soviétique à cette action qui me paraît
je m'exprime je le répète comme
quelqu'un qui réfléchit sans avoir les
données du problème toutes les données
du problème qui me paraît être une faute
mais faute ou pas cela doit être
condamné mais à partir de là est ce que
cela doit être condamnée de telle sorte
que chacun fasse un monte un degré dans
les shales quel est le poids limite à
partir duquel on sait que l'on n'accepte
pas la force et le moment où soi même on
ajoute à l'épreuve de force aux éléments
tels que ceux là doivent déboucher sur
la guerre
je pense que je pense que les chemins de
la paix peuvent se trouver mais ils
obligeront tous les responsables du
monde à repenser les bases de la société
internationale qui a été fondé au
lendemain de la deuxième guerre mondiale
monsieur mitterrand que pensez vous de
la position du parti communiste français
sur ce qui se passe en afghanistan
je vous les ramenez non je vous remettez
vous estimez vous la ligne sur l'union
soviétique ou pas je considère que ce
problème sur lequel je vais m'exprimer
puisque vous poser la question ce noeud
m'évade rep a pas de raison les airs
mais je pense que c'est peut-être plus
intéressant de continuer l'analyse que
nous pouvions faire évader
j'ai lu comme vous même la position du
parti communiste espagnol par exemple
qui condamne
j'ai dit tout à l'heure quand on
hésitait sur son devoir la ligne est la
plus claire c'est de rechercher les
principes simples
le parti communiste espagnol dit pas
d'intervention militaire en mettant le
jeu la paix la détente et on attend à
l'indépendance d'un peuple
si le parti que la milice italien avec
peut-être un peu moins de clarté mais
tout de même est allé dans le même sens
je pense que le parti communiste
français en ne le faisant pas manque au
principe sur lequel nous avons fondé la
démocratie à l'intérieur de notre pays
et entre les peuples
est ce que tous ces événements récents
compromettre votre prochain voyage en
une saison
je ne suis en rien mêlé aux événements
récents je ne pense pas qu'il soit sage
pour la france dix ans ce qu'elle a à
dire pour autant de rompre ses relations
avec l'union soviétique
je ne pense pas d'ailleurs qu'il faille
mais les de trop près les problèmes qui
se passe en asie centrale avec les
problèmes propres aux relations des deux
blocs militaires d'est et d'ouest qui se
partagent l'europe
donc cela n'a rien à voir avec le sujet
bien être entendu si j'allais zain
moscou et si je m'entretenais comme
c'est prévu avec les responsables
soviétiques je leur parlerai un langage
aussi clair que celui que j'emploie
aujourd'hui devant vous alors puisque
nous parlons états du monde ont dit que
le monde et est en partie déstabiliser
en raison de la faiblesse des états unis
tels jugements vous portez sur le plan
interne la faiblesse des états unis bon
normalement l'agencé tap à partir du
watergate et deux sortes d'interrègne
qui a correspondu à la présidence de
monsieur ford le déclenchement les
affaires du portugal où souvenez et puis
le formidable contentieux né de la
guerre du vietnam et de la guerre du
cambodge
les etats unis ont traversé une phase où
leurs faiblesses
c'est pas simplement politique et
militaire mais morale et quand on songe
à ce que représente dans l'histoire du
monde contemporain
la présence des états unis animé par une
certaine philosophie de la vie une
certaine morale de l'histoire on à
mesure la déchéance de ce grand pays que
je regrette bien entendu
n'est ce pas parce que leurs dirigeants
sont fragiles et jade est jugée est en
tout cas ils n'ont pas su mener les
destins de leur peuple dans la ligne de
leur histoire cela paraît évident et que
la russie soviétique et mesurer cette
faiblesse en et profiter je le crois où
je le crains mais comme la russie
soviétique ne peut pas aller beaucoup
plus loin puisqu'il n'est pas question
pour elle bien qu'elles tiennent déjà le
yémen du sud bien quelqu'un déjà un
certain poste en ethiopie bien quel bar
le sud de la mer rouge
donc le nord nord ouest de l'océan
indien
bien que l'afghanistan ne trouve pas la
mer enfin soit comme une sorte d'avancer
vers l'océan indien de l'autre côté je
ne pense pas il baptise envahiront le
pakistan je ne pense pas que l'union
soviétique veille de la guerre cela
serait contraire à tout ce qui a été
accompli par monsieur brejnev simplement
il prend des risques et il n'a pas le
droit de les prendre sous mitterrand le
frison adli vous adresser une lettre
est ce que dans une situation de crise
grave vous accepteriez de faire partie
un petit peu de cette équipe de france
dont il parlait avanthier a lancé sur
l'équipe de france ce fut un peu
rap du vocabulaire je lis à la france
l'équipe de france dès constitué par les
53 millions de français dans l'appel à
l'unité du morceau we longtemps pia mais
le consensus elle veut rien dire si cela
ne repose pas sur une politique capable
de répondre aux aspirations de la
majorité des français or dans un pays
d'inégalités d'injustice marquée
notamment par la discussion sur le
budget actuel par les misérables mesure
qui vient d'être prise milliard et demi
bien entendu et c'est une bonne chose
que ce milliard et demi soit aujourd'hui
sous faure 250 francs par mois pour un
seul mois en compensation de hausse qui
elles dureront indéfiniment le cas
échéant en salle avant tout ça cette
politique de fiction d'apparence je
dirais même de poudre aux yeux ne peut
pas inciter un responsable politique
comme je le suis premiers secrétaires du
parti socialiste représentant des forces
populaires ne peux pas me faire engager
dans une discussion sérieuse sur ce
fameux consensus dans ce n'est pas
possible simplement lorsqu'il s'agit des
intérêts vitaux de la france pays sur la
surface de la terre parmi dans notre
puissance mêlées au conflit ou désordre
qui occupe à l'heure actuelle le monde
bien entendu ses intérêts vitaux non
seulement nous autorise mais nous oblige
à débattre et à discuter à dire ce que
l'on pense au responsable des affaires
publiques
il sait dans quel esprit alors que vous
vous rendrez alizés nous n'en sommes pas
là le président la république a parlé un
peu conditionnelle en disant si les
choses s'aggravent est à lui de prendre
les initiatives
le parti socialiste a déjà déclaré que
notre analyse à nous était que la
situation était suffisamment grave pour
que nous acceptions de parler ce qui ne
veut pas dire que nous soyons prêts à
consentir aux décisions qui seront
prises
nous sommes en démocratie il ya
maintenant 18 mois nous avons pris cette
pollution nous sommes pas prêts d'y
revenir
monsieur bara d'hier soir j'affronte les
réalités les autres parlent alors il y à
un choc pétrolier estimez vous qu'il est
grave non mais non monsieur va
n'affronte pas les réalités comme il
conviendrait de les affronter ce n'est
pas exact
ça aussi c'est la façade
voyez par exemple le budget avec le
budget à la suite d'événements vue
est-ce qu dont la responsabilité incombe
entièrement au gouvernement vous savez
que du g20 il faut le reprendre
une session extraordinaire qui va
commencer lundi prochain et bien ce
budget vous imaginer n'importe quel
homme ou femme de bon sens imagine
qu'avec tout ce qui s'est passé au cours
des six derniers mois
avec tout ce qui se passe actuellement
le train de hausses formidable
l'augmentation du pétrole les données
sur lesquelles on l'a établi au mois de
septembre dernier sont plus les mêmes eh
bien monsieur bart au nom du réalisme ne
veut pas changer un iota
alors que le parti socialiste lui vend
ou projet tel qu'il a été établi au mois
de septembre et nous sommes déjà au mois
de janvier
et il n'entrera en vigueur qu'au mois de
février pour peu que ça marche bien je
veux dire pour peu qu'ils aboutissent à
obtenir un vote favorable
bon alors je dis que monsieur bart n'est
pas de sireli ce qu'il le paraît depuis
je pense que la nécessité d'aujourd'hui
elle devrait être une nécessité
permanente de l'histoire en démocratie
c'est d'expliquer et de faire comprendre
honnêtement a su à qui on s'adresse aux
français la réalité des problèmes et
parler du pétrole comme on le fait bien
entendu le pétrole avec 100 milliards si
tout de même un choc
c'est un choc bien entendu mais
s'abriter derrière ce seul argument pour
tenter d'expliquer l'échec de la
politique économique du gouvernement
s'est trompé les français s'est trompé
d'abord les français sur l'explication
songez qu'à l'heure actuelle lorsque un
consommateur automobiliste va prendre un
litre de super à la pompe
il va payer maintenant 19 centimes de
plus que les 3 france 05 ou si ce qu'ils
trouvaient ici ou là songez que sur ces
trois francs 22
7 ainsi 27 les deux tiers ou presque les
deux tiers sont constitués par des taxes
que l'état impose sur le prix du pétrole
se dire qu' il n'y a qu' un tiers qui
représente l'extraction du pétrole sa
production son transport son raffinage
et il faut beaucoup d'opérations pour
cela le circuit commercial qui l'amène
depuis le raffinage jusqu'à la vente
un tiers seulement et le milliard et
demi que monsieur bart vient de
consentir aux foyers modestes et aux
individus dans le besoin correspond
exactement au milliard et demi qu'il
vient de récupérer sur l'augmentation de
la taxe sur le prix de l'essence
aujourd'hui mal quand je dis que ce
n'est pas l'épreuve de vérité que de ne
pas expliquer que l'augmentation du prix
du pétrole
si lourdement affecté par l'augmentation
des taxes en même temps des impôts
correspond aussi aux extraordinaires
fluctuations du dollar
c'est à dire que les pays producteurs du
pétrole sont dans des situations aussi
incertaine par rapport à ce qu'ils
pourront tirer en argent de leur pétrole
que nous le sommes nous lorsque nous
l'achetons 3 mi temps mais ça s'est
jamais expliqué aux français puisque
nous évoquons la situation monétaire je
vous demander de faire comme nous
l'avons fait hier avec raymond barre de
regarder le petit reportage que jean
claude renault a réalisé aujourd'hui à
la bourse de paris
car après la folle séance d'hier le
marché de l'or est devenu bien instable
lingot a baissé de 13% et le napoléon
lui s'est littéralement effondré il est
passé de 11 130 francs à 611 ce matin
devant la boucle du petit épargnant
agglutinés devant les officines de
change voulait vendre et réaliser le
plus violent
même s'il venait pour information
rêvant du napoléon soit 1 et maintenant
vous voulez en acheter ou au mans on
atteindra sont pas payés à 12h15 en face
les cotations commence sur le marché de
l'or de paris le sous-sol de la bourse
est surchauffée côté influences et la 3e
journée historique
laure est toujours en folie mais à la
baisse la barre côte 71 8 500 m au lieu
de 83 milles hier le napoléon baisse
trop vite lorsqu'il atteint 715 au lieu
de 11 centres entière le marché est
suspendu pour une demie il y a trop de
vendeurs et pas assez d'acheteurs à la
reprise en code d'abord le lingot 73
1850 au lieu de 80 4900 trains ir en une
séance il a perdu plus d'un million de
centimes la cotation du napoléon sera
suspendu deux fois à 14h41 enfin il est
cotée à six ans plus bas qu'avant pied
malgré cela les petits épargnants qui
ont fait la queue toute la journée sont
toujours dehors devant le crédit de la
bourse et ils veulent vendre quand la
porte s'ouvre
c'est la rue
à la caisse les pièces d'or se change en
billets de banque mais impossible de
savoir si le petit épargnant a gagné ou
perdu
c'est peut-être le silence de la journée
des dupes sous mitterrand le premier
ministre n'avait pas été scandalisés par
cette hausse de l'or par ces mouvements
étaient montrés inquiets mais papa très
organisé qu'est-ce que vous avez une
hantise
j'ai regardé les images là avec vous
savez c'est un monde qui met tout à fait
étranger je vois ça cette agitation ce
mouvement et j'en suis stupéfait je mets
jamais arrivé en toute hâte participer
c'est parce que c'est bon mais
naturellement en tant que responsable
politique je dois bien me poser quelques
questions et je pense que le phénomène
de la hausse insensée ces derniers jours
je crois qu'on avait un train de 30% de
plus que la valeur du métal et la chute
soudaine correspondent à des mouvements
passionnel d'inquiétude vous
enthousiasme pour gagner de l'argent à
bon compte et que tout cela révèle un
formidable désordre dans les esprits qui
est tout simplement l'écho du désordre
dans le monde bon alors je ne peux pas
philosophie longtemps là dessus je n'ai
rien d'autre à dire sinon qu il n'est
pas possible de tenir de cette façon
longtemps avec un or qui monte anciaux
finira par précipiter un tas de braves
gens diraient des gens très modestes
dans une crise de leurs foyers qui
serait dramatique
trois conducteurs de se laisser aller à
ces spéculations pour s'inviter en une
thèse dit que la crise en général c'est
un les gouvernants en place donc le
vraiment un public mais aussi d'une
annotation vous même au sein de votre
propre part ça c'est focus excuse est
pas une occasion pour vous de vous
déterminer en fonction de cette élection
présidentielle tout le monde pense en
france et tout le monde en tout le monde
en parle surtout c'est vers 15 mètres
autour du pensez donc à vous d'imaginer
tout ce qui peut se passer d'ici là mais
les noms des futurs candidats sont
surtout maintenant si maintenant
maintenant c'est maintenant si la crise
sert le gouvernement on pourrait dire
que le gouvernement met un malin plaisir
à perpétuer la crise vraiment j'espère
quand même que ce n'est pas volontaire
dans ce cas là enfin il deviendrait
compétents très compétent pour faire des
crises
je ne pense pas quand même qu ils
s'abaissent à ce niveau pour préparer
une élection présidentielle en ayant
défrayé tout le monde à la fois par la
situation extérieure décrites dans les
termes dramatique et paris situation
intérieure présentée de la même façon
non je ne crois quand même pas cela de
mes adversaires politiques
alors vous voulez à tout prix parler
s'était enchaîné on a le temps on a le
temps quel sera le candidat socialiste
en 80 sous le sort et moi aussi on
l'apprendra le jour ce sera décidé
moi je n'en sais rien non plus vous
allez libérer michel rocard de sa
promesse c'est pas du tout ça va mal
écouté à compter du moment où un de mes
camarades du parti socialiste déclare
qu'il ne présentera pas sa candidature
contre moi ou avant que je ne me sois
prononcer n'ayant pas l'intention de
m'engager dans cette bataille
présidentielle
à seize mois de distance
comme si la france avait pas autre chose
à faire et on vient d'en parler
maintenant depuis 10 minutes à 12
minutes comme si la france n'avait pas
autres to fall à faire sur le plan
national et international
avec la crise des foyers avec la
difficulté de chaque ménage pour finir
son mois avec une ombre chômeurs avec
l'augmentation des prix avec les menaces
qui pèsent sur la détente et le
qualifiant sur la paix pourrait que
c'est le moment pour le un parti comme
un autre de se consacrer uniquement à
régler les problèmes internes pour
savoir quel est son meilleur candidat
une bien entendu cela devra se faire
arrêter le jour venu dans un délai
raisonnable que les instances
dirigeantes du parti socialiste
déterminons je ne suis pas mandaté pour
vous en parler ce soir monsieur
mitterrand les événements politiques
étrangers je voudrais simplement viré
véniel brême que je n'ai pas besoin
d'autres qualifications pour assumer mon
mandat et ma mission je suis le premier
responsable du socialisme en france
et j'entends bien assurer cette
responsabilité autant qu'il le faudra
bon alors je pas besoin d'autres vite
qualification je fais ce que j'ai à
faire je suis le premier responsable
du parti socialiste en france pour
l'instant cela me suffit nous verrons
bien pour la suite tienne vous
embarrasse pas que monsieur rocard est
au silencieux
je n'ai pas du tout l'intention de
débattre avez vous de ces choses
allons-y partie de miss paris oui les
événements politiques étrangères
actuellement creuse le fossé entre le pc
et le ps notamment sur lui la nonne la
non réaction face à l'intervention
soviétique en afghanistan sont en effet
que le parti communiste en agissant
ainsi s'éloigne de plus en plus des
bases sur lesquelles nous avons signé le
programme commun de la gauche dont le
fondement même était le droite à
l'indépendance nationale les droits de
chaque peuple de se déterminer lui même
on a le droit d'être inquiet devant
cette évolution d'un parti qui après
avoir fait l'effort en 1972 d'aller vers
des définitions politique acceptable
dans une démocratie semble toujours dû
s'en éloigner
non monsieur mitterrand vous n'êtes on
ne se fait plus le candidat de toute la
gauche est ce que vous n'avez pas tord
que vous avez les remet dans la
stratégie de l'union de la gauche dont
apparemment les communistes ne veulent
lui-même mademoiselle c ne mentaient
absolument pas je je je vis avec mon
temps j'observe l'évolution des
événements j'ai constaté comme beaucoup
d'autres que malheureusement pour notre
peuple
le parti communiste n'avait pas voulu en
1978 que la gauche emporte à la victoire
depuis cette époque les choses autant
pires et ses responsabilités ce sont
donc aggravé je considère qu'il
appartient désormais au parti socialiste
d'assurer lui-même le mandat qui avait
été confiée à la gauche toute entière
et pour cela il faut que le parti
socialiste soit capable de dire oui
quand il faut dire oui que dire non
quand il faut dire non et d'abord au
parti communiste c'est ce que je ne
manque jamais de faire ensemble terrain
je remercie d'avoir été notre invité
pendant un bon quart d'heure ce soir
donc dans notre journal
jean matteoli pourrait reprendre ses
fonctions à la fin du mois le ministre
du travail avait cessé toute activité il
ya 40 jours après une affection
cardiaque hier soir pendant le journal
nous apprenions l'inquiétante
augmentation du taux de
radioactivité de certaines âmes de près
de l'usiné nucléaire de la hague
et bien ce soir plus de détails aucun
danger pour l'instant dit la direction
pour l'instant mais pour demain question
de feeling dumez avec des rejets
radioactifs répéter est ce qu'il n'ya
pas un risque d'accumulation les rejets
qui sont effectués par les installations
nucléaires entre dans le cadre des
normes si c'est par la réglementation de
la santé publique
dans le cas particulier
l'incident qui s'est produit à la suite
des très fortes tempêtes dont vous venez
qu'elles ont déplacé des gros galets par
exemple à être ta ont porté préjudice à
la canalisation de rejet mais ce qui se
passe c'est qu'il est simplement
changement de l'emplacement du rejet en
mer au lieu d'être rejeté loin en mer le
projet se fait plus près de la côte
mais le contenu même des rejets n'a
absolument pas été modifié ça ne peut
pas avoir de conséquences plus près de
la côte que loin les mesures qui ont été
faits qui sont faites sont faites dans
le domaine nucléaire un niveau qui est
très au dessous de celui qui présente un
risque pour la population ou pour les
espèces animales ou végétales
de toute façon les mesures qui sont
faites sont faites à titre préventif et
c'est bien je crois
la caractéristique de grande fierté
qu'on a en ce qui concerne la
radioactivité c'est que contrairement à
ce qui se passe dans d'autres domaines
on n'attend pas que le risque soit là on
fait des mesures réelles avance très en
dessous et dans le cas particulier les
résultats
les variations qui ont été mesurés ne
sont significatives ni du point du samu
r ni du point de vue écologique il ne
peut donc pas y avoir d'accumulation de
radioactivité disons exceptionnel pas
d'accumulation un niveau qui puisse prod
porter préjudice à la santé ou même à
l'équilibré des espèces si ça arrivait
qu est ce que vous feriez enfin avec des
si vous savez on peut faire des
hypothèses
on peut faire rentrer le parti paris
dans une bouteille si ça arrivait et
bien des mesures seraient prises de
toute façon actuellement comme vous le
savez à titre encore deux précautions
aucun rejet n'est plus effectué jusqu'à
ce que les canalisations ont été réparés
jean marie le pen président du front
national inculpé de provocation à la
discrimination raciale à l'origine de
cette inculpation d affiche du front
national où on pouvait lire un million
de chômeurs c'est un million d'émigrés
d'immigrés pardo entre aux réactions de
jean marie le pen
la mesure insolite dont je fais l'objet
est de nature à mettre en péril les
libertés politiques sociales pas de
rupture mais pas d'accord non plus dans
le conflit des contrôleurs aériens après
la réunion hier au ministère des
transports à un nouveau rendez vous a
été pris il ya 20 ans mourait albert
camus l'auteur de la peste et de
l'étranger rouler dans une voiture qui
allait percuter un platane près de sens
dans l'yonne
le véhicule avait été entièrement
pulvérisée philosophe moraliste écrivain
tout court albert camus est aujourd'hui
aussi luc avant sa mort surtout par les
jeunes qui apprécient dans son oeuvre
son goût pour la vie et je n'oublie pas
que albert camus fut membre de l'équipe
de combat je pense à lui en vous disant
vous apprenant que france soir dimanche
va cesser de paraître
lancé il ya trois mois france soir
dimanche sans inquiéter le journal du
dimanche avec tout de même devancé par
son chiffre de vente
le figaro dimanche sport pour terminer
reprises dimanche des compétitions de
ski deux épreuves ce jour-là tout
d'abord fontaines eau en allemagne de
l'ouest la descente
et puis à praloup donc en france la
descente hommes les françaises n'ont
jusqu'à présent guère brillé et
maintenant à quand même plus d'un mois
des jeux olympiques d'hiver de lake
placid aux états unis plus précisément
le 13 février
on se pose beaucoup beaucoup de
questions
la coupe du monde de ski en ce mois de
janvier amorce un virage décisif
elle entre dans une deuxième phase qui
nous conduira aux jeux olympiques dans
l'équipe de france beaucoup de problèmes
restent en suspens et le patron des
équipes tricolores honoré bonnet a mis à
profit ces quelques semaines de repos
pour remettre de l'ordre dans ses idées
chez les féminines le rideau se lève
dimanche en bavière au petit village de
fontaine la descente verra les débuts de
caroline attia rétabli après sa blessure
à l'épaule survenue à val d'isère qui
confondent tout le monde pense que les
jeux peuvent être considérés comme un
but mais finalement je ça sera une
course comme une autre et je ferai le
maximum mais une course comme une autre
carolina tiens ne semble donc pas
particulièrement effrayé par la
proximité des jeux olympiques dans la
discipline du slalom fabienne serra
devrait enfin éclater comme l'ontt vexé
de n'avoir pu décrocher autre chose que
des places d'honneur depuis le début de
la saison
elle connaît la même motivation que la
petite grenobloise perrine pellen ici
très brillante appelant cavale et si du
côté féminin on est plutôt optimiste
côté masculin en revanche rien de sarran
honoré bonnet à rechercher de nouvelles
solutions en compagnie de patrick russel
ici responsable des slalomeurs et
surtout de gens bérange jean bérenger a
toujours dit qu'il ne fallait pas
attendre de résultats dans l'immédiat
car cette équipe de france masculine a
beaucoup travaillé sur le plan physique
les éléments sont jeunes et le travail
paiera plus tard ce n'est cependant pas
l'avis de jean pierre soisson tir après
l'eau dimanche où se tient une épreuve
de la coupe du monde de ski tiens à dire
que si les skieurs français
les chercheurs comme en descente
notamment ne manifeste pas leur
possibilité de figurer en première série
eh bien ils n'iront pas les placides aux
prochains jeux d'hiver qui sont tout
proches tout cela m'amène à vous parler
de la météo de la neige aujourd'hui sur
le nord l'est le jura les alpes et la
bourgogne sur le reste du pays temps
nuageux avec une hausse des températures
pour demain et bien ciel couvert dans
l'est et en montagne avec de la neige au
dessus de 500 m attends pas très
réjouissant vos loyers pour cette fin de
semaine au prochain rendez vous avec
l'information tout d'abord ce soir à
22h55 le dernier journal présenté par
hervé claude demain samedi et demi sera
20 ans après la mort de fausto coppi
consacré au cyclisme d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui georges bégoux jean paul
ollivier et robert chapatte recevront
pour en parler louison bobet raphaël
géminiani et bernard hinault
à 20h le journal présenté par léon
zitrone qui est déjà sur ce plateau pour
se préparer à passer la nuit ici et être
à votre compagnie donc à 20h avec une
édition spéciale dans ce journal
présenté par jean-pierre elkabbach qui
est consacré à et qui sera consacré
la détente la détente en crise où la
crise de la détente en tout cas les
menaces de guerre inquiète évidemment
les responsables politiques mais aussi
les responsables des rédactions et puis
dernier rendez vous que je vous signale
d'ores et déjà lundi soir
question de temps le magazine
entièrement réalisé par des enfants d'un
même lycée parisien ils ont entre 10 et
14 ans et on imaginer tous les
reportages que nous vous présenterons
pendant presque deux heures
et puisque nous parlons d'enfants une
démarche que nous faisons rarement mais
pour aider les recherches montre la
photo d'un petit garçon âgés entre 2 et
3 ans qui a été trouvé le soir du 1er
janvier à paris dans le 18e
arrondissement personne n'est encore
venu le réclamer alors si vous avez des
renseignements sur sa famille vous
pouvez téléphoner au 354 13 32 le numéro
ne s'inscrit pas sur votre écran le
voici 354 13 32 ou bien 3 154 81 43
brasse ce journal est maintenant tout à
fait terminé avec un tout petit peu de
retard passé une excellente fin de
semaine
bonsoir à lundi